En un video anterior comenzamos a pensar en la
energía potencial como función de la distancia
internuclear para las moléculas diatómicas. ¿A
qué me refiero con moléculas diatómicas? Bueno,
observamos el hidrógeno molecular o H₂, que son
sólo 2 hidrógenos unidos por un enlace covalente,
y a temperatura y presión estándares la distancia
entre los dos núcleos se mide desde la energía
potencial más baja. Si tuviéramos que juntarlos
más, tendríamos que agregar energía al sistema
y tener una energía potencial más alta, o si
queremos separarlos igualmente tendríamos que
agregar energía en el sistema y tener una energía
potencial más alta. Lo que quiero hacer en este
video es resolver un pequeño ejemplo práctico.
Por aquí tenemos tres energías potenciales
como función de los gráficos de distancia
internuclear, uno de ellos es hidrógeno molecular,
otro es nitrógeno molecular o nitrógeno diatómico
N₂ y otro de ellos es oxígeno diatómico. Y lo que
quiero que hagan es que pausen el video y piensen
cuál gráfico corresponde a la energía potencial
como función de la distancia internuclear
para cada una de estas moléculas diatómicas. Y
les daré una pista: observen el punto más bajo de
energía potencial, el punto más bajo de energía
potencial es lo que normalmente observaríamos
como la distancia internuclear de la molécula
diatómica a esta temperatura y presión estándar,
y esta distancia estará en función de dos cosas:
estará en función de qué tan pequeños son los
átomos, qué tan pequeños son sus radios. En
general los átomos más pequeños van a tener una
distancia internuclear estable más pequeña. Y
la segunda cosa es el orden del enlace entre
estos átomos. Y les daré una pequeña pista:
el hidrógeno diatómico sólo tiene un enlace
covalente, el nitrógeno diatómico tiene un
enlace triple y el oxígeno diatómico tiene un
enlace doble, por lo tanto, cuanto mayor sea el
orden del enlace más cerca estarán los dos átomos
y también tendrán una energía de enlace más alta,
la energía requerida para separar los átomos.
Recuerden: hablamos de eso en el video anterior,
esto de aquí es la energía de enlace. Y dicho
esto, pausen el video e intenten resolverlo. ¿Cuál
de estas es la gráfica de H₂, cuál es de N₂ y cuál
de O₂? Entonces, primero pensemos en términos de
energía de enlace. Si vemos aquí el enlace simple,
el enlace doble y el enlace triple, esperaríamos
que el enlace de orden más alto tenga la energía
de enlace más alta y la energía de enlace más alta
es ésta de color salmón, justo aquí. Con base en
esto diría que este es un buen candidato para N₂,
entonces este de aquí me parece que es nitrógeno
diatómico. Luego la siguiente energía de enlace
más alta, si miramos con cuidado, es esta púrpura
aquí, y así con base en el orden de los enlaces
diría que este es un buen candidato para O₂, y
entonces la energía de enlace más baja es ésta
justo aquí. Y sólo con base en el orden del
enlace, este es un sólo enlace covalente, este
parece ser un buen candidato para el hidrógeno
diatómico, pero también pensemos en los radios
de estos átomos. Si vemos la tabla periódica de
los elementos, podemos ver que el hidrógeno sólo
tiene un electrón en ese primer nivel, por lo que
será el más pequeño. Entonces tiene sentido que
su distancia desde donde está la energía potencial
más baja sea más corta para la molécula diatómica
que está formada por los átomos más pequeños.
Pero luego, cuando miramos a los otros dos,
sucede algo interesante. Recuerden: el radio de
los átomos aumenta entre más bajo estén en una
columna, pero a medida que se avanza hacia la
derecha en una fila, su radio disminuye porque
estamos agregando más y más electrones a la misma
capa, pero las fuerzas de Coulomb están aumentando
entre la capa más externa y el núcleo. Así que si
sólo observamos esa tendencia, cuando pasamos del
nitrógeno al oxígeno, en realidad esperaríamos
que el radio atómico se reduzca un poco;
están uno al lado del otro, puede que estén cerca
pero si decimos "Está bien, el oxígeno tiene un
electrón extra en el mismo segundo nivel, tal vez
sea un poco más pequeño". Entonces, si nos basamos
sólo en esto, diríamos "Bueno, la distancia
internuclear para esta gráfica de color salmón
es un poco más corta. Tal vez esa sea oxígeno y
tal vez esta sea nitrógeno". Pero estaría cerca,
y diría que en general el orden del enlace
tendría mayor prioridad y e orden del enlace,
ya que vemos esta alta energía de enlace, es
el mayor indicador de que esta será la molécula
diatómica de orden de enlace más alto ON₂. Están
cerca en radio atómico, pero esto es lo que hace
toda la diferencia. Tomamos esos dos átomos de
nitrógeno y los apretamos un poco más a pesar
de que podrían ser un poco más grandes, por lo
que me siento bastante bien con esta respuesta.